So Republican Congressman Louie Gohmert from
Texas, one of the wackiest and most ignorant
members of Congress out there has tested positive
for corona virus.
Now, Gohmert has also aggressively refused
to wear masks, but he believes that some brief
moment of mask wearing may actually be what
gave him the virus.
I'm going to show you that video in a moment.
But as a reminder, for months, Louie Gohmert
has been seen on Capitol Hill refusing to
wear a mask.
In fact, just two days ago, he was at Attorney
General Bill Barr's hearing and walked out
of the room right behind William Barr, neither
wearing a mask.
Neither he nor William Barr wearing a mask
that is raising questions about Barr as possible
exposure.
Barr has reportedly tested negative since
Gomer said back in June that he didn't need
to wear a mask because he didn't have the
virus, but said he would put a mask on if
he were to get infected.
Apparently, he must have worn a mask at some
point because here is video of Louie Gohmert
now, Koban Positive saying, you know, it might
have been wearing a mask that gave me the
virus, but I can only wonder if by keeping
your mask on and keeping it in place, let
me if I might have put some germs from afar.
Some of the virus under the mask embrace today.
I don't know.
But I got it.
We'll see what happens from here.
But the reports of my demise are very premature.
The mask gave him the virus, but he doesn't
really wear masks, if you can imagine this.
He was actually scheduled to have some kind
of birthday barbecue fundraiser later in August
where donors were going to be given.
Meet and greet access to him.
That crazy Fox News host, former Judge Jeanine
Pirro, was going to be there as a special
guest.
No word on what's going on with that event.
No word from Fox News as to whether Jeanine
Pirro would still be part of the event if
it were going to happen.
But the mask wearing has become very, very
partizan at this point.
There's an axios Ipsos poll from a few weeks
ago which found that two thirds of Democrats
are wearing masks all the time when they're
outside their homes in public, whereas only
about half that number, 35 percent of Republicans
are wearing masks.
So it is a significant partizan divide.
And that plays into remember my report from
earlier this week that what has forced Trump
or pushed Trump to change his tone on Corona
virus has been that advisers went to him and
said, you know, it's disproportionately our
people.
That's the word they used our people who are
getting this.
So it might be bad from an election standpoint
if this continues.
Now, a few other things to show you on this.
Louie Gohmert went on Sean Hannity's Fox News
program last night and Sean Hannity was encouraging
him to take hydroxy chloroquine.
And Gohmert said, yeah, I'm taking it.
And it was barely coherent.
He called it Hydra Jocke C Chlorine or something
like that.
Take a look at this here.
A guy at, say, Cedar Sinai that knows more
about hydroxyl chloroquine than anybody.
Have you thought about any of these if you
talk to your doctor about it?
Any thoughts on it for yourself?
Yes.
Yes, I have.
And thanks for the discussion you've had about
it.
You know, you've talked about the one study
that said it affected have to be withdrawn.
So, yeah.
And I'm doctor and I are all in and I got
a text just before I came on.
Dear friend, doctor that just found out he
had it and he said he started it, didn't you?
Regimented.
So Zain charism arneson and 100 jox chlorine.
And that will start just in there, too, you
know.
So thank you.
So, Gomer.
How is this real life, Gomer?
Not only has no idea what he's taking, he
actually says that Hannity's propaganda coverage
of hydroxy chloroquine at least partially
influenced his desire to take it.
And then just one more little video for you.
Here is Republican Congressman Kevin McCarthy
calling Louie Gohmert, Congressman Kofod and
then correcting himself.
You want to be able to trace it, put him out.
And just as Congressman Coverts, Congressman
Louie Gohmert says that he doesn't have any
symptoms, there could be other people like
that.
So what?
What a world.
What a world that we live in.
That's just perfect.
I think going forward, I should refer to Louie
Gohmert as congressman covered.
Now, let's get serious for a second.
Herman Cain went to Donald Trump's Tulsa,
Oklahoma rally or Tulsa.
Some people say, and he was then diagnosed
with coronavirus.
He has now died.
And there is every reason to believe that
Herman Cain, former presidential candidate
and supporter of Trump, caught the virus at
Trump's Corona rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
He is dead now.
OK, so when we talk about this, I take no
pleasure in Herman Cain dying of Corona virus,
even as it appears he caught it at an optional
rally that Donald Trump did.
But we've just got to be serious and realistic
here.
When I talk to people in other countries,
people like Louie Gohmert and these other
moron Republicans, they often come up.
And sometimes people in other countries just
can't even understand what's going on.
Like, how is it even possible for people like
Goma to get elected?
How is it even real life that Donald Trump
is holding a rally with sixty five hundred
people indoors in Tulsa, Oklahoma, which now,
as far as we believe led to the infection
of Herman Cain and subsequently the death
like, did Trump kill his friend by having
that rally?
Is that is that a crazy thing to say?
How is it even possible that Louie Gohmert
is elected?
And you really just have to understand the
United States to understand that?
I mean, I understand the electorate in the
Texas 1st Congressional District.
These are not ad homonyms, the Texas 1st Congressional
District, where Louie Gohmert is elected and
the read the district that he represents,
it's wildly right wing.
Trump got 72 percent of the vote in the first
district of Texas in 2016.
Mitt Romney got 72 percent of the vote in
2012.
McCain got 69 percent in 2008.
Bush got 68 and 69 percent in 2000 and 2004.
This is a wildly right wing area and that
correlates at this point in time, 2020 in
the United States, disproportionately with
anti science beliefs.
Texas is first district has even more pronounced
Texas problems.
Texas is not a place with.
Secularly good health care.
Texas is not a place with particularly good
education.
It's extra not good in the first district
of Texas.
So this is a complicated place.
They tragically keep electing Louie Gohmert
and we're seeing the consequences of this
anti science ideology.
One of the things I'm going to talk about
at the start of tomorrow's program is that
Dr. Anthony Foushee is now in the unenviable
position of having to beg and plead with America
to listen to science and doctors.
That's where we are.
Meanwhile, look at what's happening in New
Zealand.
Look at what's happened in South Korea.
Look at Vietnam.
Look at, you know, Greece placed dramatically
different places culturally, geographically
and economically.
All have figured out how to deal with the
virus.
And this is what we're dealing with.
This is a tragedy.
And, you know, the human debt, the human toll
party aside, is my priority.
I don't want anyone to get the virus or die.
But there is one side that has been the cause
of these problems and they must be held accountable.
If they are not, what's to prevent them from
doing exactly the same thing?
Next time